here's a big story that's uh almost uh
what's over five years old now almost
six years old from Politico Ukrainian
efforts to sabotage Trump backfire you
heard it right here from News Guard
certified Politico
100. yes check it out and they say
Ukrainian government officials tried to
help Hillary Clinton and undermine Trump
by publicly questioning his Fitness for
office they also disseminated documents
implicating a top Trump Aid and
Corruption and suggested they were
investigating the matter only to back
away after the election and they helped
Clinton's allies research damaging
information on Trump and as advisors a
political investigation found Kenneth P
Vogel and David Stern how is this story
still on Politico when they later came
out I think it was political eu's
reporting from my I believe it could be
wrong Natasha Bertrand sang this story
was in fact Russian disinformation yet
it's still up right now yeah and we we
Derek and I we know a lot about this
this story because we brought this story
up over and over and over again during
the Ukrainian preachment hoax I mean
this is one of the stories that proves
that it's a hoax the whole the whole
first impeachment of trump was a hoax
it was I mean they accused Trump of what
they had done exactly
so Joe Biden I love this we had we had a
guest on the show I'll I'll give him the
courtesy of not saying his name but
people know who it was we had this
younger guy he was like a anti-woke guy
and then he went liberal and we're
sitting down we're talking to him and I
said Joe Biden sitting at his meeting
what was it Luke was it Atlantic
counselor or was it CFR
um with uh Joe Biden talking about yeah
that was
cfrid the president of the CFA yeah he's
like encyclopedia on these meetings so
far bad bad people so Joe Biden says I
told them if you don't fire the
prosecutor you're not getting the
billion dollars and they said what you
can't you have no Authority I said call
the president see what he says six is I
look at my watch you got six hours the
prosecutor's not five you're not getting
the money well SOB guy got fired and I'm
like so an illegal quid pro quo the vice
president has no authority to override
certified loan guarantees from the US
government he can't do that he did it
they accused Trump of doing that Trump
never asked for anything but this is
what Joe Biden literally did amazing and
here he is now sitting as president yeah
so Donald Trump
stumbles upon this in my opinion I don't
think Trump knew all that much about
what was going on I think Trump saw a
Twitter video of Joe Biden saying this
that went viral because the phone call
transcript was funny he's like what is
this thing you know with Biden saying
the loans you know why don't you look
into that right he didn't even know what
he was talking about and then they
probably panicked like no we can't have
him digging into that impeach impeach
it's amazing Biden was not running for
office at the time and the media ran
with Trump is targeting his rival what
rival Joe Biden the dude it's old and
not running for office nobody thought he
would I I think some people speculated
he would run but there was no definitive
answer whether he would but that's the
angle they went with Donald Trump
stumbled upon some very serious
corruption and I think people need to
understand this what's happening in
Ukraine I think has long been planned I
was there on the ground in in the end of
2013 and I think into early I think it
was end of 2013 when the maidan protests
were starting then it was a few months
later I had left they ousted Yanukovych
this was this was an escalation that had
been happening quite a bit Russia was
took takes Crimea
Donald Trump gets elected everything
stops
Donald Trump loses Joe Biden is now
president Russia conflict Ukraine starts
up again it's amazing how that happened
how if you just
use a a modicum of common sense that
when when Barack Obama is in office this
this conflict is escalating Joe Biden is
is shaking down this country
and then when Trump said everything
stops yeah and it's not just Biden that
was shaking it down I mean Biden was one
of the top guys shaking it down but
there's there's so much so many of these
people in Washington DC that represent
these countries I mean we don't even
know the half of of yeah of of how many
people were on the payroll of these
these ukrainians Democrats and
Republicans I think Ukraine is what a
vassal state of NATO of the United
States you know uh you you've got Russia
running the gas prom pipeline through
the country jacking up the prices into
Europe causing a lot of problems the U.S
wanted to build the cutter turkey
pipeline Syria said no the US says oh
look lucky us Bashar al-assad is facing
a Civil War and we just happen to
support the other people it's it's it
seems very obvious what the whole thing
was really about and why they wanted to
demonize Russia over China yeah yeah I
wanted to ask you what did you think
about Trump's foreign policy towards
Ukraine and Russia because you made some
assertions about Obama being kind of
soft on Russia uh what did you think of
Trump's job what how did he do because
he was also the first president to send
lethal weapons to Ukraine which some
people at the time saw as an escalation
yeah well look
if you look at what if you look at what
Trump let's talk about the big picture
and back up and then go back to the
propaganda
so remember every time Trump would make
a move
they would say he's an idiot oh I can't
believe he said that this is
embarrassing
and you know a lot of us were sitting
back saying well wait a second you know
we've been having these you know I would
go to these meetings and you know I I
spent a lot of time overseas I mean
Colonel Harvey was was with me in a lot
of these meetings and we would go meet
with some anywhere from our allies to
okay people to some really bad people
you know
and
I was just glad for the first time
because you know I was always as a as a
you know chair of a committee and and
top Republican you know you never want
to go we always kind of had a rule that
you know the the partisanship stops once
we once we leave the country right and
you try to put forth you know good faith
effort overseas so you know with with
Republicans Democrats you don't want to
be fighting your political conflicts
over there just makes for confusion
anyway I'd sit in those damn meetings
with I remember specifically sitting in
a meeting with the Germans knowing that
they were that they were shutting down
their nuclear power plants and they were
they were getting ready to put this
pipeline additional pipeline in to be
solely reliant on Russia
and I was thinking to myself and I
always kicked myself sometimes when you
think I should have said something I
should have done something
and um and not that it would have
mattered at the time but I said you know
you know I felt like saying what the
hell are you guys doing you know and
sometimes I'd have little sidebars like
what what the hell you guys doing with
this you guys are shut down these
nuclear power plants this is this is
crazy so when Trump goes over there and
says okay cut all this [ __ ] out
here's what we're gonna here's what
we're gonna do why are you buying these
why why are you putting this pipeline
why are you shutting down your nuclear
power plants you guys are crazy why
aren't you putting in the money to Nato
I mean you know how many times I would
go to Nato and we'd sit there in these
stupid meetings and everybody you know
oh you know I can only put in 1.2
percent I'm supposed to be put into I
mean this has gone on for three or four
Decades of these guys not putting in
their money
yeah and and so what Trump remember like
that was just like what he said was not
crazy it was actually just common sense
but they should be pain and they
shouldn't be shutting down their nukes
and they shouldn't be buying gas from
Russia because if you do and the
Russians decide to ultimately shut off
your gas
now what the hell are they gonna do now
they got a hell of a mess I mean look
this thing could get really bad
but in in Germany in in Europe this
could get really bad if the Russians
decide to shut this gas off here in the
next two months it's going to get back
it's going to use winter as a weapon but
Trump offered American Natural Gas you
want gas we'll provide it to you he
provided the Eastern Europeans
especially the polls military assistance
and you know weapon systems and things
that the Obama administration had been
denying built relationships with Romania
in other countries okay
he focused on Russia doing things that
the Obama Administration did he was
building up NATO and pressuring NATO
which the Democrats accused him of
dividing NATO and weakening NATO but he
called him out and he got them to
increase
funding by a hundred and forty billion
dollars
which still wasn't close to the two
percent but it was more than we had ever
gotten out right I'm just imagining
these NATO countries they're like I will
gladly pay you Tuesday for a missile
defense system today and then every week
it's just the same thing you know that
famous line who is that guy the
cheeseburger guy you know was it Archie
Comics so so did you agree with uh with
Trump's policy did you think he did a
good job when it came to navigating
Russia Ukraine in that situation the way
it's unfolding right now and and more
importantly yeah I mean I think look
probably the best thing that he did uh
overall was how he dealt with China yeah
I mean when he said he was going to put
in those tariffs
I thought to myself oh [ __ ] I've Heard
I've heard this every you know I've been
around watching every president oh we're
gonna really get tough on China and I'll
be damned if you didn't do it but but
specifically where we are now and
especially your work on the intelligence
committee how dangerous is the current
situation that we're in now especially
with this kind of proxy war between the
East and the West unfolding in Ukraine
right now
um it kind of depends on it's tough to
get good analysis out of there right
yeah so
look Russia could do some real damage to
Europe this this winter it's that's
that's a serious issue that we just
talked about
secondly it kind of depends on what I
think the Russians are you know have
they lost 30 000 50 000 100 000 who
knows what the right number is
um but you know the Russians clearly
thought they were going to go in there
march to Kiev and that the ukrainians
were going to lay down their guns and I
will tell you that I mean there's I
think number one it's hard for them to
no matter how much they censor
there's still a lot of young people that
they're that really they're conscripts
that the Russians are relying on but you
know they know that they know ukrainians
they know each other the ukrainians
never want to have the Russians back I
mean they know what it was like the old
I mean you have a lot of the old the
guys that are fighting for the
ukrainians right now are guys that were
that were in the Russian military I mean
you've got guys that are 40 50 60 years
old that were brought up and trained you
know by the Soviets that are now running
their military operations the Russians
are relying on a lot of conscript
they've lost if look let's just call it
what do you think or only lost 50 000
probably for sure probably but that's
that's killed we're not talking about
all casualties but they watched a
thousand would mean what 200 250 000
casualties thanks for checking out this
segment from the timcast IRL podcast but
if you want to check out the full show
live tune in Monday through Friday at 8
pm and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there